apple just released their new 2019 ipad
for three hundred and twenty nine
dollars and they made it seem like a
really great deal but in this video i'm
going to explain exactly why you should
not buy it
during apple's iphone event they showed
off all the cool features that make a
scene really awesome but in reality it's
almost identical to the 2018 ipad the
displays been bumped up to ten point two
inches from nine point seven but you
still have the same large bezels all the
way around apple showed off a massive
three point five million pixels but the
2018 ipad already has that apple also
compared it to a cheap laptop and said
it's 2.5 times brighter but the 2018
ipad has the same 500 nits of brightness
Apple showed off the 810 fusion chip
that has two times more performance than
the cheap laptop but that's the same
exact chip that already comes in the
2018 iPad in fact you get the same old
touch ID sensor the same stereo speakers
the same battery the same 32 gigs of
storage the same old charger the same
lightning port the same colors the same
outdated Bluetooth 4.2 the same old gen
Apple pencil support the same rear
camera and the same super outdated 1.2
megapixel selfie camera which looks
terrible
Apple also showed off support for the
new iPad OS software but the 2018 iPad
also supports iPad OS literally the only
things that changed for the display size
in the addition of the smart connector
which allow you to attach an Apple
keyboard now that sounds pretty nice
until you find out that the keyboard
itself is priced at a whopping a hundred
and fifty nine dollars nearly half the
price of the iPad itself and to be
completely honest that extra cash would
be much better off going towards one of
the 2019 iPads which are better in every
single way there is only one thing that
held the 2018 iPad back and that was the
810 fusion chip which struggled to keep
up with games like fortnight pub G in
asphalt 9 and unfortunately we still get
the same exact chip in the new iPad so
in my honest opinion do not buy the 2019
iPad for just 56 dollars more you can
get the iPad Mini 5 on Amazon
with free prime shipping that iPad comes
with a powerful 8:12 Bionic chip in a
much better display and if you want a
larger size you can get the 2019 iPad
air for just four hundred and sixty nine
dollars and trust me it's many times
better in every way
now what if you don't want to spend
three hundred and eighty-five dollars on
an iPad well to be completely honest
you'll be better off just getting the
2018 iPad brand-new for only two hundred
and fifty dollars on Amazon and you
should order it quickly because trust me
it's gonna sell out really fast well
link that down in the description below
you'll save $80 and you don't have to
wait until the end of the month for it
to be released now I do want to mention
the only reason why I would buy the 2019
iPad instead Apple's TV plus
subscription service is coming out on
November 1st and Apple mentioned that if
you buy a new Apple device you'll get
one year of streaming for free
that's a $60 value which brings the
price of the new iPad down to two
hundred and sixty nine dollars which I
would say is actually worth it for $20
more than the $250 2018 iPad however
that deal also applies to the new 2019
iPads as well making them an even better
deal if you buy them from Apple but
beware if you're already planning on
buying something like the new iPhone 11
the Apple TV Plus deal doesn't stack so
you'll still only get one year for free
either way we're still ordering the 10.2
inch iPad to make comparison videos and
see if anything else has changed so if
you're not already subscribed click that
circle above and check out our videos on
the iPhone 11 pro and Apple watch series
5 right there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]